bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin alors les prix du
carburants atteignent des sommets les
appels à manifester se multiplient sur
les réseaux sociaux avec notamment ses
appels à reprendre les ronds-points
paris gilet jaune la mobilisation
justement des gilets jaunes est-ce
qu'elle redémarre ou est-ce qu'on est
finalement dans la continuité du
mouvement
on est dans la cantine parce que ça fait
trois ans que les jets les jaunes sont
sortis dans la rue bientôt à cette
longue en quoi elle sera le vingtième
anniversaire et gilet jaune
donc elle n'a jamais cessé
certes alain peu aeby et c'est normal
qu'au bout de deux trois heures de
manifestation leur passion pour le tiers
des violences bas des personnes sont
parties mais là ça c'est un redémarre
tas de manières pas puisque alors je
vous parle
150 points qui ont été
alors on sait également qu'il ya des
mobilisations toujours contre le pass
and i ter ce que finalement c'est le bon
moment pour se faire entendre sur le
sujet du carburant
bah oui c'est le bon moment
fortement le gasoil l'essence
également ne dit jamais assez les
produits de première nécessité les pâtes
le riz aujourd'hui en france y'a quand
même 10 millions de français qui vivre
qui vivent sur le seuil de pauvreté donc
c'est le bon moment il n'y a pas un
moment particulier et les jets les
jaunes d'oeufs passant un coin bien
s'inviter dans les mois qui viennent
dans le débat essentiel je vous
demandais à quelques mois des élections
présidentielles on sait que ce réveil
des gilets jaunes agace le sommet de
l'état c'est une façon de dire on est
toujours là car les choses n'ont pas
bougé jusqu'à aujourd'hui
j'ai fait depuis trois ans les choses
dans la cité le chiffre de 10 millions
de français qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté le mouvement les jaunes étant
enclenchée par eux par l'augmentation du
cros d'essence et apparemment le gong le
gouvernement d'un appareil qui prennent
des mesures urgentes soient bloquées
déplaire à fond mais on peut pas rester
dans cette version n'est pas possible
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure des
ronds-points qui commence justement être
investis par les gilet jaune est ce que
vous avez une idée de la mobilisation
aujourd'hui à paris à quoi faut-il
s'attendre
aujourd'hui
les passions
entre le passé ni terre et pour la
justice sociale donc je les jeunes
espèrent évidemment une cohabitation
mais je crois qu'il parcourt bien sûr et
en province et notamment sur les ronds
points
depuis ce matin tout le monde s'organise
pour venir en coin et comme je voulais
incidemment
150 fois qu'ils devraient être
merci beaucoup david basskin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat et cofondateur du
collectif robe noir et gilet jaune